hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry phd skincare nerd
and someone who really likes foaming
cleanses there are a lot of myths about
firming cleanses and the ingredients in
foaming cleanses and how to use foaming
cleanses so today i'm going to be
busting some of these myths
i asked you all to send me cleanser
myths and my instagram stories and i got
so many replies thank you so much it was
actually really helpful
because there were so many myths that i
already had in mind
but also so many that i just forgot
about a word of warning before we begin
the answer to a lot of these
is going to be it depends it won't be a
simple yes or no
i know it isn't as satisfying and a lot
of us just want certainty but
unfortunately a lot of stuff in skincare
is quite complex
a lot of the time the research hasn't
really come to a firm conclusion yet
and a lot of myths do have a little bit
of truth to them i also talk more about
cleansing and all the other important
steps in a skincare routine in my ebook
the lab muffin guide to basic skin care
so check that out if you want more info
the first myth is are foaming cleansers
always bad for your skin
are foaming cleanses harsher than other
cleansers this used to be true
back in the day with older cleanses the
only ingredient that was commonly used
to make lots of foam was sodium lauryl
sulfate a bit of background on cleansing
ingredients cleansing ingredients are
called surfactants they have this sort
of structure they have a head that likes
water
and a tail that likes oil the two
together in the one package means that
surfactants can help oil lift off skin
and surfaces
and disperse into water so you can
actually rinse it off
sodium lauryl sulfate is a surfactant
and it happens to be quite skinny for a
surfactant
that means it can penetrate into skin
more easily and stay there
and that's what leads to irritation and
that type feeling you sometimes get
after you wash off a cleanser but with
newer cleanses
firstly there are lots more ways to
produce lots of foam
and secondly there are ways to formulate
with sodium lauryl sulfate that stops it
from
being quite as irritating first let's
talk about foam products that foam a lot
don't necessarily clean better
and they don't necessarily irritate more
the three can correlate but they don't
always
it's like owning cats versus happiness
versus spending a lot of money
the three are sort of linked but not
really so
foam cleansing and irritation they all
have a lot to do with surfactants
but foam making is to do with how well a
surfactant stabilizes a liquid film that
is trapping air
cleansing ability is to do with how well
so factors pull oil and dirt off skin
now you might have thought that
cleansing too well cleansing too much
stuff off your skin
is also what causes irritation and
scientists thought this for a really
long time but it turns out that's not
the main reason for irritation
the main part of irritation is actually
how well a surfactant burrs into skin
and stays there and disrupts your skin
barrier with foam there are now lots of
surfactants that can foam really well
without being as irritating as sls
leukocytes betaine cell chains ether
sulfate sarcomas torades isothionates
are all very good at foaming there are
also lots of non-surfactant ingredients
that are really good at stabilizing foam
and these don't necessarily add to
irritation so these are things like
glycerin and thickeners
foaming pump tools are also getting more
popular so even if a cleanser doesn't
foam well when you just rub it on your
hands the packaging can
increase the foam there are also lots of
ingredients that can be added to
cleansers to make them less irritating
and this is a lot more common now
for example it turns out that adding
emollients which are moisturizing
ingredients to a foaming cleanser can
make it less irritating than a
non-foaming cleanser without these added
ingredients
in this study over five days the
non-foaming cleanser actually dried out
skin
while the foaming cleanser with these
added emollients actually increase skin
hydration over the five days
so yeah modern foaming cleansers can be
very very gentle
that actually ticks off another myth i
got asked which is can cleanses actually
hydrate and moisturize skin
and this study seems to say yes some can
and
this makes sense because cleansers can
actually deliver active ingredients
which i'm going to talk about a little
bit later but first i wanted to talk
about sulfates
are sodium lauryl sulfate and sodium
laureth sulfate as bad as everyone makes
them out to be
again historically sodium lauryl sulfate
was quite harsh
but in modern cleanses there are lots of
ways to make sodium lauryl sulfate less
harsh
the most common way is to combine sodium
lauryl sulfate with other surfactants in
them one cleanser
and this is really common practice i
don't remember the last time i saw
sodium lauryl sulfate in a cleanser by
itself the way this works is
once you mix a cleanser with water you
get lots of individual surfactant
molecules floating around by themselves
as well as big clusters called micelles
now remember the main thing that makes
cleanses irritating is when the
individual surfactant molecules can
burrow into skin
and sodium lauryl sulfate is very skinny
it's very narrow
which means it's really good at doing
this but it can't do this when it's in a
big cluster the micelle is too big
so it's actually those individual
molecules that didn't get into the
micelles floating around by themselves
that can burrow into skin and cause that
irritation
so one really good approach to making
sodium lauryl sulfate less irritating is
to try to get more of them
into these micelles the scientific term
for this is to lower the critical
micelle concentration it turns out if
you use a bunch of different surfactant
molecules to make my cells these
mixed micelles they actually incorporate
more of the sls into them and that means
less individual molecules that can get
into skin and
less irritation using a mixture of
surfactants to do the job also means
that you can reduce the concentration of
the more irritating surfactants
there are other special technologies as
well like using polymers that stick onto
surfactants again
forming a much larger cluster and not
letting them get into your skin
another common practice is to add
ingredients that reduce irritation into
the cleanser
for example polymers emollients
hydrolyzed protein glycerin and
antioxidants
so just seeing sodium lauryl sulfate on
a cleansing ingredient list doesn't mean
that cleanser will be irritating
and if you're using a cleanser that you
really like but it happens to have
sodium lauryl sulfate in it that's not a
reason to stop using it
but if you're looking for a cleanser and
your skin is quite sensitive or prone to
dryness and irritation
and there are a few different cleanser
options you're looking at maybe picking
the one that doesn't have sodium lauryl
sulfate
might be a better bet so that is sodium
lauryl sulfate what about sodium laureth
sulfate well i think sodium laureth
sulfate just got swept along with sodium
lauryl sulfate
because they sound kind of the same and
the word sulfate is really easy to say
there's an older experiment that tested
the urgency of a range of different
surfactants including surfactants that
we still use a lot now
sodium laureth sulfate turned out to be
the mildest
as well as beating sodium lauryl sulfate
it also beat two other sulfates t
a lauryl sulfate and ammonium lauryl
sulfate and it beat these ones and you
can sort of see why these didn't really
take off in the fear-mongering states
dissodium cocoa ampheta sodium lauryl
sodium lauryl
sodium lobe i am a trained chemist with
a phd
dissodium cocoa amphodia acetate sodium
lauryl amphoacetate
sodium coco methyltory do you have to
cleanse your skin for a certain amount
of time 30 seconds one minute two
minutes
the answer is no not really your skin
doesn't have to marinate in cleanser to
work but
using a cleanser for a little bit longer
might give you better results
let me explain so i mentioned that
cleansers have surfactants and they
arrange themselves into clusters called
micelles
when you use the cleanser what has to
happen is the oil and dirt has to make
it into the middle
of the micelles so this situation on the
left has to rearrange itself into the
situation on the right
the oil has to break up into droplets
and get suspended
into the water by the surfactants once
you have these emulsion droplets they
can be rinsed away it's sort of like the
oil is dissolving into the water
so to make them rearrange you have to
shuffle stuff around
the molecules quite like being in the
second version so if you jostle them
around enough
they'll naturally rearrange like that so
that's what you're doing when you're
rubbing a cleanser on your face you're
jostling everything around and trying to
get this oil to break up into these
emulsion droplets you can also use a
cleansing brush or a sponge or whatever
to make them move
molecules also wiggle around a lot
randomly so if you just leave it they'll
eventually bump around enough that
they'll rearrange into that second
version but if you're adding movement
using your fingers or a cleansing brush
or whatever then you don't have to wait
as long
it's like trying to clean an oily plate
you could leave it in soapy water for an
hour
or you could scrub it and you'll be done
in 10 seconds so
time isn't really the limiting factor
it's moving the molecules around enough
that they rearrange into the second
version so you can wash them away
obviously you can't physically rub the
cleanser all over your face in half a
second none of us are the flash i think
flash
if you're watching hi but if you could
it would be enough
so that's why these recommendations for
30 seconds one minute two minutes can be
helpful
it's the same logic as brush your teeth
for two minutes or clean your house for
15 minutes every day
if you make yourself spend more time
doing something then that indirectly
makes you do it more thoroughly even if
there's no magic behind the exact length
of time itself
now the problem with leaving a cleanser
on for too long so for example if you
leave it on like a mini mask even though
the directions don't say that
is that it can be irritating cleansers
are designed to be washed off your skin
if you look at the recommendations for
ingredient usage by formulators so
how much of an ingredient you should be
putting into different products
for potentially irritating ingredients
the amount for a leave on product
is going to be lower than the amount for
a wash off product
and that is because of the different
contact time the longer you leave
something on your skin
the more time there is for the
ingredients in that product
to get into your skin and for some
ingredients you don't want that so for
example the surfactants there are lots
of factors used in rinse off cleanses
that shouldn't be left on skin
so the longer you leave that cleanser on
your skin the more time those
surfactants have to burrow into your
skin
and stay there and cause irritation
other ingredients with different
recommendations for leave on and wash
off are things like fragrances
preservatives essential oils so the
moral of the story is don't just let a
cleanser sit on your skin for those 30
seconds or one minute or two minutes
make sure you're moving it around on
your skin
otherwise there's no extra benefit to
leaving it on now there is an exception
with cleanses that contain
actives where the instructions actually
say to leave them on your skin for a
certain amount of time then hopefully
they did their due diligence they tested
it on lots of people and they found that
most people didn't have
issues with that extra irritation in
which case just follow the instructions
now whether or not active ingredients
can actually work in a cleanser
obviously a cleanser doesn't stay in
contact with your skin for as long as a
leave-on product so there's less
opportunity for the ingredients to
penetrate your skin
and get to where they need to be to work
so the challenge is
making that ingredient stick to the skin
better than it stays in the cleanser and
so when you rinse it off
there's still stuff stuck to your skin
with face cleansers there are a few
active ingredients that can be
successfully delivered so for example
salicylic acid benzoyl peroxide
if we look at other cleansing products
as well with body washes they can
deliver oily substances really well like
stearic acid lanolin alcohol
plant oils and even dha which is the
active ingredient in self tan
if we look at shampoos we have
anti-dandruff shampoos that deliver
those active ingredients
purple shampoos can deliver purple hair
dye and two-in-one shampoos can deliver
conditioning ingredients
so it's definitely possible that
cleanses can leave behind enough active
ingredients to make a difference to your
skin
and they don't all wash down the drain
and i'm sure there's tons of other
actives that can be successfully
delivered that just haven't been studied
yet the problem is
a lot of the time you need to have a
special delivery system to convince the
ingredient to stick to your skin
in general if it's something more oil
soluble then it tends to stick to skin
better the problem for us as consumers
is that it's really hard to tell if a
product has the right delivery system
unless the brand actually tells you and
leaving it on your skin for too long can
cause all of those problems that we
talked about before
so i would still recommend leaving
cleanses on your skin for as long as the
product says to leave it don't leave it
on for like five minutes
and expect to have good results at that
point you are probably doing more harm
than good
in general i would probably recommend
using a levon product rather than a
cleanser if you really want an active
ingredient it's just a bit more reliable
there's a lot more evidence for leave on
products and you don't have to worry
about how long to leave it on your skin
for but there are definitely some
situations where a cleanser with active
ingredients might be a better option
if your skin is quite sensitive to a
particular ingredient then using it in a
cleanser might be a better choice
you can also apply the levon product and
just wash it off after 10 minutes or 30
minutes if you're worried about
irritation this has been shown to work
quite well for some ingredients like
retinoids and benzoyl peroxide
i talked more about this short contact
therapy in my video about starting on
retinoids
i think it's also a really good idea for
benzoyl peroxide apart from the
irritation there's also the fact that
benzoyl peroxide is a massive pain in
the what what
in the benzoyl peroxide also bleaches
things like pillowcases and clothes and
towels
benzoyl peroxide is also like the
ingredient that causes
issues with layering it inactivates a
lot of other active ingredients
so if you just wash it off before you
apply the rest of your routine
you don't have to worry about it so
those are the most popular cleansing
myths i got asked about i'm sorry if i
didn't get to your myth i will hopefully
cover it next time
like subscribe notification bell you can
also check out my blog and follow me on
instagram
i'll see you next time for more nerdery